it's always fun to see a kid take them
out or take the field jeff for the first
time as a
major league player and there's the
dream for ian anderson look i i think
anytime you get to see a young guy like
this come up and make his debut you're
just excited to see him pitch congrats
ian and let's see what he's got we say
it so often you think of kids making
their major league debuts how many hours
they spent in the backyard throwing a
ball against a garage door a brick wall
dreaming of a moment like this
and anderson just worked a one two three
inning with a changeup has his first big
league strikeout starting lineup great
to see ronald acuna jr back in that lead
off spot fly ball hammer deep left field
welcome back ronald he admires that baby
three quarters of the way up the
bleachers there's that home run you
talked about jeff a lead off shot and
acuna is back with a bang it's one
nothing a
473 foot tape measure homer by acuna to
start the game
there's the o2
struck about swinging a lead off homer
for ronald lacuna jr it made garrett
cole mad he struck out the next three
we're shooting he's got a great
curveball that he really hadn't showed
him yet might see it here
nope it's the heat and anderson blows it
right on by second strikeout six up six
down shut down inning after the braves
gave him a one-run lead ian's the first
atlanta starter to make his debut
against the yankees well let's see what
he does 3-2
through it again and gardner swings and
misses that's three strikeouts for ian
anderson so he's in scoring position now
for talkman who has a 2-2 count good
speed at second for wade the 2-2 pitch
is up the middle but dansby had him
played perfectly and that will retire
the side
three hitless innings for ian anderson
in his debut no major shift on for
dansby
voight's way off the line at first
and a slider
missed and garrett cole turns his back
on the home plate umpire and walks back
behind the mound before he gets the ball
back
it was not in the strike zone so he's in
scoring position
for swanson who struck out his first
time up
driven toward right talkman drifting
back that ball carries to the track out
by that brick wall that ball is gone a
two-run opposite field homer boy you can
see how frustrated garrett cole is the
pitch that preceded the home run ball
he turned his back on the homeplate
umpire
sanchez wanted to give it back to him
cole didn't even look at the up and then
serves up a homer on the next pitch it's
a slider away he goes with it to right
field fourth home run for dansby this
year zuna struck out his first time
this ball is launched to left center
field and deep that one's going to fly
way out of here
three homers for the braves today
it's four to nothing
they've hit about five miles worth of
homers against one of the best pitchers
in the game today he's gone to more off
speed stuff now which as good as it is
not his strength and marcel
did not miss out no runs no hits no
errors for the yankees gary sanchez
leads off the fifth inning
line oh want to stop riley scrambles to
his feet and throws him out how big
might that play be in the sixth or
seventh inning a hot smash sanchez
retired one out great play by austin
got up took his time and threw it across
the diamond to freddie great job one
ball two strikes
strike three of fastball froze him at
94. gardner
is out number two wade ready here it
comes
and is tipped and caught five strikeouts
and five no-hit innings for ian anderson
who enjoys a four-nothing lead in game
one kids pitched
five no-hit innings against the yankees
but to to mix pitches up like that you
know what a job he's done here is luke
voight
and he swings hits a fly ball to right
back is marquez on the track at the wall
she's gone the luke voigt it's one two
detroit
he homers
like where swanson hit his to right
field and just over the wall so that is
the first hit that
ian anderson has given up the yankees
are on the board and they trail 4-1 2
outs for ford
he did a swing and a miss good call jeff
and wow six innings of one hit one run
ball for ian anderson in his major
league debut nine times out of ten will
put the ball in play and that's the
braves need here to bring home freddie
freeman who doubled to start the inning
down the left field line that's going to
turn into gold gardner comes to a
sliding stop freddy scores ozuna to
third he's in safely and marcake is with
a stand-up double makes it a 5-1 atlanta
game shane green on to try and close the
deal for ian anderson and the braves
today and this will be
miguel andrew hard
first pitch swing and that's rifled
toward left that ball's deep that ball
is trouble but it is going to be caught
at the wall duval tracks it down and the
braves have beaten the yankees
5-1 your final score